les polémiques la politique les
législatives on en parle ce soit avec
mes invités j'accueille laure salvaing
directrice générale de kantar public
france bonsoir à vos côtés catherine
tricot directrice de la revue regards
j'accueille aussi pascal perrineau
politologue professeur émérite à
sciences po et bien sûr notre chronique
sérieuse que laëtitia cru pas kim
accompagnera tout au long de l'émission
bonsoir laetitia d'abord une question
est ce que vous avez trouvé j'interviens
convaincant catherine tricot il a à
peine fait des excuses c'est tout il a
maintenu son interprétation c'est à dire
voilà trop de billets m'enfin là il ya
quand même une question que tout le
monde peut voir on a bien de les voir à
nouveau c'est que la police a participé
du problème je ne dis pas qu'ils
n'avaient pas de billets en plus
probablement qui en avait en plus eh
bien ça mériterait de le savoir parce
que entre quelques centaines et 35000 ya
quand même de la marge
personne ne croit véritablement qui
avait quarante mille personnes en plus
sur le parvis du stade de france ce
quarante mille personnes vont vraiment
bien ça fait vraiment du monde ou alors
il a tenté de donner des explications on
l'a vu en expliquant que certains
étaient repartis dès la première mi
temps avait repris le rer dans l'autre
sens c'est extrêmement crédible mais
surtout ce que je pense qu'il est apparu
c'est que qu'il y ait eu des problèmes
c'est possible mais ce qui est quand
même très ennuyeux c'est quand la pop la
police participe du problème et là on en
l'occurrence c'est ce qu'on a vu et n'a
pas été capable d'anticiper elle n'a pas
vu le problème de la grève de la ratp
elle n'a pas imaginé qu'il pouvait y
avoir des biens en plus elle à anticiper
donc été mal renseignés mal préparée et
puis surtout c'est qu'elle a appliqué sa
doctrine qui est une doctrine de
considérer que la foule comme
potentiellement émeutière c'est à dire
qu'il ya tout le temps cette attitude je
dirais quasiment militaire de relation
avec la foule est là en l'occurrence
tous les témoignages qui nous reviennent
y compris de vos confrères et consoeurs
qui étaient présents 10e heureusement
que les supporteurs de liverpool était
extrêmement calme nous avons appris les
supporters pour des oliviers à l'an
dernier exactement alors que
heureusement qu'ils étaient calmes et
que finalement ils ont empêché un
mouvement de panique qui est plus
vraiment se traduire par des morts et
quand gérald à mende darmanin dit on à
éviter les morts ben peut-être que les
morts ne sont pas venus mai par la grâce
de la queue du calme des supporters de
liverpool du tout l'action de plafond
des policiers donc là je pense ya quand
même une vraie question qui a été posée
dans le reportage qui est il faut quand
même qu'on s'interroge sur la doctrine
de la police française qui fait que
depuis 2016 en gros les manifestations
tournent souvent vinaigre et que là
maintenant on se rend compte que ça
déborde des manifestations et ça devient
sur les magnifiques fallait
rassemblement massif et tout le monde a
en tête un mais voilà dix millions de
personnes en bord de seine il faudrait
que ça se passe pas comme à nantes quand
et où la fête de la musique où ça se
donner un mois ont fait choisir ausy si
des choses sont gérées comme on a géré
la fête de la musique à nantes où comme
on vient de gérer le stade de france
mais ça n'a pas bien ce père si cela
semble pour cela que gérald darmanin a
dit qu'ils avaient peut-être revoir un
peu leur façon de procéder notamment à
des questions politiques qu'il faut
qu'ils devraient être mises en débat et
puis peut-être regarder un peu ce qui se
fait ailleurs en europe parce que c'est
quand même ça devait une exception
français alors c'est une question
politique et on assiste également à un
moment de vie démocratique avec le
parlement qui était dans son rôle pascal
perrineau oui c'était rassurant
d'ailleurs parce que parfois on se
demande dans cette démocratie si le
contrepoids parlementaire s'exprime
véritablement à l'assemblée nationale
étant donné la situation
dans l'assemblée nationale sortante on
s'aperçoit du fait que voilà la majorité
a été comme toutes les majorités le
doigt sur la couture du pantalon et n'a
pas exercé véritablement sa fonction de
contrôle du gouvernement et que cela
revient revient au sénat hélas une fois
de plus la commission des lois du sénat
bien fait son travail toutes tendances
politiques d'ailleurs confondues
trouvera écologistes de gauche de droite
et on a pu un peu
avancé dans l'accouchement difficile de
la vérité c'est de la transparence
déclamé par le prennent mal quand même
sachant que cela porte à conséquence
parce que la france s'apprête à
accueillir de très grands événements
sportifs et s'il n'y a pas un changement
dans la fois de politique de l'ordre
public pour le cadre des événements
sportifs vont peut être extrêmement
inquiets parce que il est vrai qu'il y
avait des supporters qui étaient plutôt
porteur de ce qu'on pourrait appeler un
flegme britannique relativement bien
connu et heureusement mais il y avait
aussi on l'a bien vu des banques qui ont
l'habitude d'intervenir qui sont des
bandes elles de petits délinquants
autour du stade et qui n'ont pas été
contrôlés tout le monde était logé à la
même enseigne la paisible familles
britanniques avec le petit loubard qui
cherchait un peu en découdre pour vous
une audition commerce a clos la
polémique non sa clope à la polémique sa
clope à la polémique parce que la
défense certes il ya eu des excuses du
bout des lèvres du ministre de
l'intérieur mais ça ne clôt pas l'app la
polémique parce que le ministre de
l'intérieur est responsable du maintien
de l'ordre public dans des événements
qui ne sont pas des manifestations ne
s'agissait pas d'une manifestation hier
il s'agissait d'un gars enfin il
s'agissait d'un grand événement sportif
est là le moins qu'on puisse dire c'est
que les forces de l'ordre la politique
telle qu'elle a été déterminé par le
préfet de police par le ministère
l'intérieur n'étaient pas à la hauteur à
la hauteur du défi lorsque la caisse que
les français vont retenir quel peut être
l'impact
selon l'opinion publique je dis ça parce
qu'il ya eu un sondage paru aujourd'hui
de vos confrères de chez oddo que ça qui
explique que 90 % des français pensent
que l'emprunt des personnes interrogées
comme toujours dans les sondages pensent
que cela entache durablement l'image de
la france à l'étranger notamment les
trois quarts sont en colère et ça peut
avoir des ça peut laisser des traces me
faire comme ça alors tout dépend
effectivement de la suite
de cette histoire parce qu'on en est
j'ai l'impression qu'au début finalement
on n'a pas encore fait la lumière sur
toutes les responsabilités
toutes les dimensions c'est vraiment un
sujet multidimensionnelle ce qui est sûr
c'est que nous nous avons interrogé la
population entre dimanche et lundi dans
le cas de notre baromètre
epoca pour pour le figaro magazine qui
sera publié ce week-end et en fait on
voit que darmana est plutôt stable
il est même en légère progression ils
gagnent un point il gagne un point par
rapport à la dernière mesure qui était
il ya un mois bon alors évidemment la
polémique n'avait pas encore eu lieu
mais j'ai envie de dire dimanche il y
avait pas de sujet en tout cas dans
l'opinion certes depuis on en a parlé on
a beaucoup parlé et des explications
hier en effet donc certainement que la
ccc les prochains jours il y aura
effectivement un effet sur l'image de de
gérald darmanin mais j'ai envie de dire
c'est un sujet très politisé aussi ce
qu'on voit c'est que finalement ce qui
son soutien de bon la capacité de la
france notamment organiser ce type de
manifestation ce sont les sympathisants
de la république en marche par exemple
ceux qui soutiennent le président de la
république donc on voit bien que on est
en train de politiser un sujet qui à la
base effectivement n'a rien de très
politique parce qu'on sait que le bien
des français avec leur police s'est
dégradée aussi est-ce que ça peut abîmer
encore un peu plus ce lien là et puis ya
autre chose qui m'a frappé c'est le fait
qu'en gros on ne croit plus aux discours
officiels on ne croit plus les
explications officielles qui ne nous
paraissent pas juste pas vrai pas de
touchable du doigt les gens qui étaient
sur place disent non ça n'est pas le cas
du coup il ya cette défiance vis à vis
de la politique qui renforçait aussi à
cette défiance à l'égard de la politique
à l'égard des médias également qui est
très forte vous voyez pendant toute la
campagne notamment présidentielle on a
mesuré le sentiment qu'avait les
français de recevoir des informations
fausses ou trompeuses
plus de 60% des français nous disaient
sur tous les sujets que ce soit le
pouvoir d'achat l'europe la sécurité le
l'emploi etc j'ai le sentiment d'être
confronté aujourd'hui au moins une fois
par mois des fausses informations donc
plus politique qui ne croient plus les
gens sains liste non contenue le rappel
immédiat alors ils croient leur père
avant tout c'est à dire leur communauté
que ce soit des communautés locales ou
affinitaires il croit les personnes
finalement quand les mêmes valeurs en
tout cas les mêmes expériences aux mêmes
valeurs que en termes de communication
politique c'est un cas d'école cette
crise on se donnait une énième
communication de crise une gestion
d'urgence peut-être que là vous l'avez
raison vous avez pointé à une
caractéristique c'est que immédiatement
quasiment dans l'heure qui a suivi les
propos de gérald darmanin qui n'ont pas
dévié en tout cas on peut lui
reconnaître cette constance ont été
contredits 36 ans il a eu un premier
tweet et puis ensuite 36,9 une fois
qu'il a pris la parole n'est jamais
dévié de sa première version donc le
problème c'est qu'effectivement les
médias s'en mêlent parce que dans la
communication et l'aviation l'émetteur
le politique et l'opinion publique au
milieu il ya les médias les médias ont
relayé effectivement tous les soupçons
qui entourait la parole officielle et
donc ça renforce normalement par effet
de ricochet cette ère du soupçon qui
existent dans la société française mais
je crois tout de même que nous sommes
aussi les victimes de la défiance et il
me semble que comme il n'y a pas eu de
mort bien heureusement cette voie là ces
événements vous restez quand même dans
la société française assez loin des
préoccupations premières je vous
rappelle que quand même ça se passe à
paris certes cette football mais je ne
sais pas si les habitants de limoges de
dijon vous de marseille va se sentir
marseille non très très concernés mais
il faudra voir vous voyez j'ai
l'impression que nous avons une focale
nos journalistes politiques qui déforme
aussi un peu la réception qui en est
faite par les français alors le sénat
lui en tout cas n'entend pas lâcher la
sphère de sitôt et prévoit d'autres
auditions comme va nous le raconter
style jourdain bonjour ce livre
alors d'abord steve est ce que les
explications de gérald darmanin ont
convaincu les sénateurs ne vit pas
vraiment non pas vraiment alors ça tient
une forme d' inflexion du discours de
l'exécutif ya une forme bien de mea
culpa de gérald darmanin qui a reconnu
que les choses auraient pu être mieux
organisé lors de cette finale real
liverpool mais sur le fond gérald
darmanin est resté droit dans ses bottes
il a rappelé son argument principal le
fiasco de samedi dernier est
principalement due aux supporters
britanniques géré à la main qui a aussi
ressortir ces chiffes 30 à 40000
supporters anglais qui serait venu sans
billet ou munis bien de faux billets aux
abords du stade de france et sa 30 à
40000 fraude or les sénateurs ont du mal
à le croire malgré la brillante de
détail exposés par le ministre de
l'intérieur est bien les parlementaires
attendaient des preuves il n'en manque
pas reçu ou en tout cas pas suffisamment
alors oui surtout que dans le même temps
et bien la majorité des observateurs
considèrent que ce chiffre de 30 milles
et largement très largement surévalué
mathieu alors est-ce une commission
denquête pour être créé pour faire la
lumière sur toute cette affaire alors
certains la demande cette commission
denquête certains à l'assemblée
nationale certains ici au sénat
également on a écouté philippe bas
ancien président de la commission des
lois président et star de la commission
pénale à lui il dit une commission
denquête why not écoutez le je suis dit
pourquoi pas s'être laisse pas de ma
responsabilité propre mais vous savez
dans les prochains jours nous aurons à
examiner si réellement la vérité a été
faite alors le gouvernement a tout
intérêt à faire le plus vite possible et
souvent on appréciera s'il faut mettre
ou non en place une commission dans quel
pourquoi pas donc mai il y as an mais on
ne peut pas légalement organiser une
commission d' enquête sur un sujet bien
sur lequel planchent déjà la justice or
deux procédures ont déjà été lancés il
ya ufa qui a lancé une enquête
indépendante il ya surtout bien le
parquet qui a ouvert une enquête pour
escroquerie en bande organisée l'objet
de cette enquête porte précisément sur
l' affaire des faux billets sur ce point
il ne pourra donc pas y avoir de
commission d' enquête parlementaire mais
les sénateurs vous l'avez dit tout à
l'heure mathieu les sénateurs comptent
bien poursuivre l'audition des
responsables de l'organisation de ce
match ont un programme de cette audition
on a un programme mais pas encore de
date on va le voir ce programme les
sénateurs veulent entendre le préfet de
police de paris didier lallement ainsi
que michel cadot le délégué
interministériel au gie aux ego grands
événements ils veulent aussi entendre et
bien la version des membres du
consortium du stade de france de la fff
et de la ratp en ce qui concerne la ratp
la question avec tir vient c'est
évidemment celle qui est liée au chiffre
de gérald darmanin commencé 30 à 40000
supporters britanniques se sont
volatilisés dans la nature après s'être
vu refuser l'entrée dans l'enceinte du
stade de france et ce qu'ils ont
vraiment pris les transports en commun
pour rentrer chez eux et si oui à quelle
heure bref les auditions très technique
en perspective ici au sénat les
auditions très politique aussi merci
steam à tout à l'heure catherine tricot
après l'affairé abah d'après les
débordements sa de france qu'est ce que
ça raconte de ce nouveau gouvernement
ça raconte quand même un éclatement de
la société française incroyable ce qu'on
vient de se dire là sur le fait que
chacun à son
son interprétation en fait les histoires
si vous êtes de l'extrême droite ou
penser que c'est tout ça ça vient des
jeunes des quartiers populaires
avoisinant si vous êtes de la majorité
ce que vous venez nous dire madame c'est
qu'en fait on pense que ça vient plutôt
des billets en surnuméraire comme dirait
le promu comme dirait le ministre de
l'intérieur si vous êtes de gauche vous
vous dites quand même la pluie ça t'a
fait son boulot et sur la façon dont le
gouvernement gère cette crise là on sort
de tous les fans lui donner mais inquiet
c'est ce que je pense mais ce que je
veux dire ce que je veut pointer là
c'est que ce que je vois c'est que c'est
nous on a plus de récit commun même sur
un un événement aussi fédérateur a
priori qu'un match et avec un événement
que tout le monde a pu voir à
pratiquement direct il ya plus des
risques jeu qu'il aurait ici commun
c'est quand même la parole officielle et
voyez-vous je vais juste vous dire là ce
qui s'est passé quand steve a donné la
version officielle ici on a eu des
sourires pourquoi pourquoi on remet la
parole de gérald darmanin en cause moi
je ne sais pas où sont passés ces 34
milles mais je ne le dis pas parce qu'on
pense tout de suite qu'il a menti comme
exemple pour montrer que les sourcils
unissent de l'intérieur
civ il est sur la défensive n'est pas
capable d'unifier ce que je veux dire
c'est qu'ils ne il a complètement perdu
il est le gouvernement d'une partie de
l'électorat c7 qui c'est ça que je veux
dire c'est que en fait normalement on
gouverne on est le président de tous les
français on est au gouvernement de la
france et c est là on a le sentiment
qu'il ne rassemble sur même
l'interprétation de d'un événement comme
celui là en fait il convainc son camp
alors là je trouve que ça à grasse
assigne la profondeur de la division des
sociétés is wicked et qu'on a pu un
gouvernement de pis ces essais cessons
sa légitimité politique est très très
faible or justement légitimité politique
et puis aussi image dans l'opinion
publique ce gouvernement bornes il a
bien du mal on va bien je même sur
l'image de la première ministre que vous
avez testé dans dans votre baromètre
pour le figaro magazine
alors effectivement elle arrive à 30 %
de taux de confiance à 30% des français
aujourd'hui font confiance à elisabeth
board pour résoudre les problèmes qui se
posent aujourd'hui un record la baisse
c'est un record à la baisse aucun
premier ministre a commencé aussi bas on
avait castex qui avait commencé à 33
enfin bon vraiment pu deviner
un peu plus au oui voilà mais qui
n'était absolument pas connu d'opinion
là c'est pas comme si l esaa bête bornes
sortez de 5 ans de mandat quand même
visiblement elle n'a pas imprimé une
image parce qu'elle n'arrivait vraiment
marquante dans l'opinion et n'a rien
pour l'instant pendant ces cinq ans là
non pour l'instant tant que première mi
temps tant que première ministre a pris
deux trois fois la parole mais surtout
il aurait pu avoir un capital d'image de
ses précédents mandats jules jusque là
elle a pas beaucoup pris la parole et
les ministres non plus ne prennent pas
beaucoup la parole on a l'impression
qu'ils se mêleront qu'est-ce qu'ils ont
peur de faire une boulette ou est ce que
c'est de devoir de réserve on est c'est
vrai vous avez raison dans cette période
un peu particulière de réserve parce que
nous sommes avant le scrutin législatif
et comme pour la présidentielle il ya
des règles qui contraignent notamment
dans les médias par exemple si vous
parlez d'un candidat il faut parler de
tous les autres dont vous imaginez bien
un peu le casse-tête l'embryon mais
quand même du côté de matignon consigne
a été donnée aux nouveaux arrivants
justement mathieu dans le gouvernement
borne d'avoir la possibilité de répondre
favorablement une habitation médias pour
aller expliquer qu'ils sont pour
expliquer leur mission dans
leurs ministères respectifs et puis
aussi se présenter au grand film doit
beaucoup et quand ils ont ils sont
championnes et par là même un grand oui
vous avez raison alors des gens les
voient pas pourquoi parce que vous
l'avez évoqué les affaires abad stade de
france là qui se sont succédé ont plutôt
refroidi à les nouveaux entrants se
disant si je vais dans une matinale sur
un plateau télé on va me poser les
questions je bête mis sur le gril que
vais je réponds donc ils ont préféré
faire le dos rond et vous avez raison
mathieu quand ils sont sortis comme
brigitte bourguignon ministre nouvelle
ministre de la santé c'était à cherbourg
mardi est là pour accompagner emmanuel
macron et bien quitter elle l'accompagné
c'est à dire qu' aucun son n'est sorti
de la bouche de brigitte bourguignon
même chose pour atteindre c'est
exactement alors il faut être quand même
honnête c'est vrai que quand un ministre
accompagne un président sur le terrain
lors d'un déplacement il est voilà de
coutume qu'il ne parle pas qui laisse le
président incarner ce déplacement certes
mais quand même pour par n'diaye qui est
victime depuis sa nomination d' attaques
violentes un venu de l'extrême droite
mais aussi selon tous les observateurs
il est affublé de cette étiquette c'est
l'antithèse de jean michel blanquer elle
est surtout c'est la surprise du
gouvernement bornes on aurait pu
attendre quelques mots de pap ndiaye
aujourd'hui à marseille mais les enfants
même les enfants n'avaient qu'un seul
nom à la bouche
[Musique]
ga
bon je vois catherine que vous souffler
alors vous peut-être vous supposez que
peut-être c'est une mise en scène
gageons sûr quand même pas rayon sur la
spontanéité ses enfants c'est peut-être
aussi un choix pas même pas parler
pendant exactement il me semble quand
même qu'il ya peut être un choix une
stratégie de ce nouveau ministre de
l'éducation nationale de laisser la
polémique un petit peu faiblir et de
prendre la parole pour sa première comme
sa confrontation avec l'opinion publique
à une date que seul lui et certainement
emmanuel macron connaissent aujourd'hui
mais du coup quand les ministres ce plan
qu'avait c'est le président qui fait le
job où on vient de le voir à marseille
et c'est lui qui descendent sur le
terrain en compagnie des ministres mais
qu'ils se taisent c'est lui qui fait
campagne pascal perrineau est ce qu il
le fait par goût et ce qu'il fait par
défaut il le fait un peu par nécessité
qu'un
certainement aussi par goût c'est tout à
fait la présidence jupitérienne et puis
c'est aussi le constat de l'échec de la
macro ni depuis cinq ans à avoir généré
un personnel politique qui soit capable
de faire le job de temps en temps à la
place du président et il faut bien
reconnaître que certes m'ad'abord n'a
pas eu le temps de faire beaucoup de
discours enfin quand vous nommer une
première ministre quand vous nommer un
gouvernement c'est aussi lié à des
effets d'annoncé
là le moins qu'on puisse dire c'est que
ça fait un flop absolue
30% en effet on n'a jamais vu un premier
ministre ou une première ministre le
commencé avec un niveau aussi faible
depuis que la sofres mesure cette
affaire est maintenant kantar et d'autre
part les effets d'annoncé des différents
ministres ça n'intéresse à peu près
personne on le voit le niveau de
notoriété d'ailleurs des ministres est
très très faible entretien des poids
lourds qui émergent on l'a vu dans le
cas de grippe ils sont
et oui hein parce qu elle en effet on
est bien dans un système de pouvoir
hyper présidentiel où certainement le
président qui pourtant appel à nouveau
président de ses voeux appelle une
nouvelle méthode de ses voeux appelle un
nouveau peuple de ses voeux là il ya du
travail
est bien au fait on s'aperçoit que rien
n'a changé et que le président continue
dans cette période pré-électorale a
attiré tout de même beaucoup la
couverture à lui parce qu'on aurait pu
imaginer que cette nouvelle première
ministre soit dans le rôle de chef de la
majorité et emmène la majorité ensemble
puisque tel est le nom voilà un nouveau
nom de cette majorité la majorité
ensemble au combat législatif et comme
un cas et comme c'est pas le cas et
attention parce que si le président à la
fin des fins arrive à une majorité
législative confortable on dire ah bon
hays continue à avoir du métier mais
s'il arrive à pas par exemple à une
majorité qui ne serait qu'une majorité
relative
au père de
stratégie que jean luc mélenchon c'est à
dire qu'il personnifie au maximum cet
enjeu à législatif jean luc mélenchon
ont dit votez pour moi alors qu'ils ne
se présentent pas un lien et emmanuel
macron non plus et on et voilà on est
quand même dans six cents par titre moi
je suis pas une toute petite différence
avec jean luc mélenchon sait que à
émerger une nouvelle génération autour
jean luc mélenchon tandis que emmanuel
macron couple et est donc ça fait quand
même maintenant mais ça fait un peu
bizarre est-ce qu'on puisse aimer ne
manquerons ne se représentera pas donc
il a intérêt à avoir autour de lui les
gens qui vont mener des combats parce
qu'on ne devient pas un chef politique
ou une chef politique si on n'a pas mené
des combats pour les a pas gagnés ou en
tout cas qu'on les a rudement mener or
il ne les laisse pas mener de combat
alors que jean luc mélenchon quand même
avec son petit groupe de dix sept
députés et il les a portées et
finalement on se rend compte aujourd'hui
qu'on nous connaissons des députés de la
france à son viseur que nous ne
connaissons pas les ministres alors
puisque même étrange puisque vous en
parlez on va l'écouter jean luc
mélenchon il était hier soir en meeting
et il y croit il dit qu'il est chance
que nous avons de gagner sont assez
élevés alors ils le savent pourtant ils
ont mis le paquet ils ont compris que
c'est un enjeu si les gens pensent qu'on
peut gagner ils vont descendre par
paquets pas grave par wagon de tous les
côtés ils arriveront j'ai vu ça dans ma
vie la première fois
[Applaudissements]
il croise il dit jean les connexions
pascal perrineau ont coûté j'espère que
non parce que quand on regarde les
rapports de force certes la nuque ps
fait un bon score au plan national
mais attention elle fait moins que le
total mélenchon plus jadot plus
la caméra les analyse fabien où ça peut
aussi nos intentions de vote et d'autre
part il ya quelque chose d'intéressant
depuis que les sondeurs ont décidé de ne
plus sondés pour législatif sur des
étiquettes nationale mais sonde à partir
des candidats réel dans les
circonscriptions la du ps a perdu 4
points par exemple si on prend le
dernier harris interactive c'est à dire
que tout même ya une partie des
électeurs de gauche qui se dit mais on
va être obligé de voter pour un candidat
et les filles qu'on connaît ni d'ève ni
d'adam qui vient véritablement de la
gauche la plus extrême et quand on est
un socialiste modéré oui on le dit non
non on va aller voir ailleurs et c'est
un peu ce qui est en train de se passer
sur le terrain et cela devrait empêcher
en tout cas la capacité de la nuque
baisse à avoir une majorité absolue de
députés comme en rêve jean luc mélenchon
pour devenir premier ministre
enfin lors sa main on ne voit que lui
jean luc mélenchon dans cette campagne
surtout à gauche c'est un bon agent
électoral en terme d'image alors quand
même justement dans le bar obèses qu'on
va sortir là ce week-end à nouveau il
voit ce que je vois là on voit que
mélenchon que j'aurais pu mélenchon
dégringole par rapport au mois dernier
un hyper quatre points dans le baromètre
de popularité de cote d'avenir du figaro
magazine donc en fait on le voit
beaucoup mais je suis pas sûr que ce
soit très payant il perd notamment à
gauche et ça c'est plus inquiétant
l'hyper notamment alors non pas à
l'extrême gauche mais à la gauche un
petit peu centriste un petit peu
traditionnelle donc finalement
la stratégie de jean luc mélenchon
notamment finalement de vider un petit
peu aussi de sa substance les élections
législatives en disant j'ai l'ex régie
ça tue ça n'existe pas là nous assistons
plutôt au troisième tour de l'élection
présidentielle vous allez aimer lire
premier ministre et ses bas plutôt comme
effets n'ont pas besoin de récupérer
certaines voix mais plutôt et c'est un
peu l'effet aussi qu'on voit sur les
faits qui nous d'une manière générale
plutôt finement de conforter celui qui
est déjà en place qui connaît la
situation qui est plutôt centriste et
qui est pas qu'ils aient pas trop
effrayant pour la plupart de la
population d'ailleurs quand on regarde
la projection en sièges à réaliser
l'institut et l'ap dont on voyait le
sondage sur les intentions de vote
réalisé pour bfm tv l'express tout à
l'heure mais la projection en sièges en
fait elle ne donne pas une majorité à
jean luc mélenchon et ses alliés comme
on le voit 155 à 180 sièges mais elle de
ne pas forcément une majorité absolue
non plus à la majorité actuelle puisque
il y aurait entre 275 et 315 sièges
c'est en gros le risque d'une majorité
ric-rac dont vous parliez tout à l'heure
pascal perrineau ce qu'on peut expliquer
aux téléspectateurs la différence entre
majorité relative et majorité absolue
peut-être rappeler un précédent il a
l'idée de michel rocard en 88 comment ça
s'était passé à l'époque alors en effet
il faut avoir 289 sièges puisqu'il ya
577 circonscriptions qui sont en jeu
donc la majorité absolue ses 289 si vous
avez le bloc majoritaire à 289 290
quelques actuelle il est tranquille il
est presque trop tranquille d'ailleurs
parce que ça fait une assemblée qui
devient assemblée croupion qui exécute
le doigt sur la couture du pantalon les
volontés du président si en effet c'est
le premier groupe est là bien sûr
ensemble sera le premier groupe et qu'il
n'a que la majorité relative pour des
tas de texte il va être obligé de
composer et c'était le cas en 1988 ou
d'ailleurs le président sortant qui
avait été réélu il ya beaucoup de points
communs françois mitterrand avait lui
même
il se veut une majorité modeste ça n'a
pas été un jour pour emmanuel macron qui
n'a pas eu la modestie mitterrand pied
du coup michel rocard devait chercher
soir l'arrêt gauche communiste gauche
soit au centre et il avait des hommes
qui étaient dédiées au parlement tiens
v'là sur tel ou tel projet wallemme
plutôt chercher des chez les communistes
on va aller plutôt chercher chez les
centristes et il avait fait même une
ouverture au plan gouvernemental
il y avait des hommes de droite et du
centre qui était rentré dans le
gouvernement rocard et ça c'était assez
bien passé et au fond vous savez
réappris les moeurs parlementaire mais
au bon sens du terme un aux députés
c'est à dire la négociation voilà là où
ils peuvent aller chercher quatre entre
caux si jamais ils n'ont pas la majorité
absolue tu as droit difficilement à
gauche c'est à droite moi je pense que
nicolas sarkozy vous vous souvenez juste
un mois avant le premier tour avait dit
j'ai posé mes conditions à emmanuel
macron je lui ai dit je vous les nommez
le premier ministre et que je voulais 50
députés et puis je sais pas quoi enfin
ils avaient fasciné en tout cas ce que
la presse avait rapporté des rêves de
nicolas sarkozy mais en fait je pense
qu'avec quelque chose qui a anticipé la
situation qui peut se profiler c'est à
dire que la droite devient en fait le
groupe pivot c'est à dire celui avec
lequel la bac ronnie va devoir faire
alliance et du coup ça alors ça conforte
leur poids politique et ça clarifie
aussi c'est à dire comme ça il faut que
l'on peut quand même que les choses
soient bien claires que
le groupe des manuels macro ne va pas
chercher des alliances à gauche mais va
chercher des alliances du côté du groupe
l air mais ça arrangeait l'air aussi
parce que ça leur donne un poids
politique
et ça leur permettait de jouer dans la
vie politique qui sont très faibles
pensions à personne à gauche qui sera
susceptible de voter un texto parce qu
on traite souvent la majorité de
playmobil mais on a une opposition
playmobil aussi qu'ils ne votent que
comme son chef nous menons d'abord elles
ne votent pas et je sais pas quel est
son chef parce que pour l'instant il y
aura quand même des groupes différents à
gauche il n'y aura pas un seul groupe
n'aura pas lieu il y aura bien un
internaute voilà il y aura un groupe
france a soumises aura probablement un
groupe communistes et un groupe
écologiste c'est un groupe socialistes
les écologistes vont probablement avoir
un groupe alors qu'ils n'ont pas
actuellement et ces groupes vont avoir
leur leurs dirigeants donc il y aura pas
une homogénéité mais ce que je pense et
que l'essentiel des mesures ne vont pas
trouvé grâce aux yeux de la gauche
pensez pas que les socialistes n'ont
peuvent sur certaines mesures votées je
ne le crois pas ça ne s'est pas produit
dans le quinquennat sortant de ne vois
pas comment alors que la clarification
de plus en plus à droite s'opère et que
le parti socialiste a compris de son
côté qu'il avait intérêt à réintégrer la
gauche clairement c'est bien ce que
portent les vielles forges enfin on est
deux nouveaux identifiés comme faisant
partie de la gauche et je pense que
c'est ça que le parti socialiste va
trouver comme ancrage après il y aura
des débats au sein d'à gauche toute la
gauche n'est pas sur la position de la
france est soumise c'est certain mais en
tout cas le parti socialiste retrouve
son ancrage historique et je ne crois
pas tu vas le lâcher la position de
martine aubry par exemple qui est quand
même un leader social-démocrate tout à
fait raisonnable ou celle de lionel
jospin ils ont bien vu l'un et l'autre
qu'ils ont intérêt à ce que le parti
socialiste serait encre à gauche et
serait ancré à gauche ça veut dire ne
pas voter les mesures je dirais
importantes du gouvernement macro qui
font polémique sur notamment 60 jours
jospin de soutenir une candidature
c'est pour ça qu'ils vont pas devenir
des prêts mobile je pense pas que je
veux dire fabien roussel ne va pas
devenir le play mobil 2 de jean luc
mélenchon et je ne crois pas que lille
et fort le sera ils ne le seront pas
mais ils ont ils trouvent leur sens
enfin ils trouvent un intérêt à faire
partie de ce groupe et à pouvoir avoir
un groupe et à pouvoir s'identifier
comme faisant partie d'une dynamique
lancera une fois de plus qu'il va faire
différence c'est l'abstention tout
l'adhésion malheureusement c'est vrai
que c'est pas forcément la mobilisation
ou l'implication des citoyens
aujourd'hui on voit que c'est assez flou
encore un il ya très peu d'intérêt pour
pour ces élections
d'ailleurs l'intérêt pour la politique
même baisse ce mois-ci
dans nos données et je rajouterais juste
sur le précédent le précédent sujet sur
les législatives il ya aussi un enjeu
pour emmanuel macron d'avoir une
majorité
relativement confortable malgré tout
majorité absolue relativement
confortable parce qu'il ya aussi
horizons quand même qui a demandé qui a
négocié des sièges et je pense que
emmanuel macron saura beaucoup plus
libre et est à l'aise évidemment s'il
n'a pas systématiquement a demandé à
horizon deux parties des noirs de
nouveaux partis de loin philippe val et
à l'ensemble mais qui fait partie
d'anciens du tout à fait partie de la
coalition comme une oie mais quand même
ça être un rapport de force un petit peu
différent si emmanuel macron six
ensembles exactement et on marche à une
grosse partie ou si ils ont besoin du
modem et de et d'horizons emmanuel
macron en attendant il était aujourd'hui
à marseille
et pour parler éducation une de ses
priorités un des dossiers qui figure sur
le haut de la pile du gouvernement et on
sait qu'il a des propositions qu'ils
font en tout cas beaucoup discuté
notamment cette histoire d'autonomie de
plus d'autonomie pour les établissements
puisque on pourrait peut être permettre
à certains directeurs d'établissements
de choisir leurs équipes pédagogiques
pascal perrineau c'est une révolution ça
c'était une révolution moi qui suis
enseignant est issu d'une famille
d'enseignants je peux vous dire que pour
bien connaître le milieu c'est une
véritable révolution parce que au fond
le monde enseignant a été habitué à
vivre à l'ombre de cette notion d'une
éducation nationale pour eux le
développement des carrières les
embauches à ce fait au plan national il
n'est pas du tout question cogéré avec
les syndicats voilà cogéré avec les
syndicats il n'est pas du tout question
dans leur culture parce que c'est une
véritable culture qui a peut-être même
plus d'un siècle derrière elle il n'est
pas question pour eux de laisser
quelques places que ce soit à une forme
d'autonomie locale ou d'autonomie
d'établissement donc là je souhaite bon
courage au président et à son nouveau
ministre de l'éducation nationale hors
nouveaux ministres mais aussi une
nouvelle méthode écouter emmanuel macron
il a donné un aperçu de sa nouvelle
méthode c'était aujourd'hui à marseille
notre ambition avec monsieur le ministre
c'est ensuite dans les prochains mois de
pouvoir généraliser cette approche est
ce dire partout sur le territoire on
veut définir en quelles que soient ses
grands objectifs
mettre des moyens mais mais donner la
possibilité
à nos enseignantes nos enseignants et
l'ensemble des parties prenantes qui
font l'éducation c'est aussi les les
chefs d'établissements les parents
d'élèves les associations de
périscolaire avec les élus et bien de
justement permettre à notre école
d'avancé de continuer d'avancer de tenir
ses promesses alors il considère
marseille comme une forme de laboratoire
il où trônent en fait une forme de droit
à l'expérimentation
c'est une bonne chose je crois que c'est
intéressant comme idée le problème c'est
qu'on va pas faire une révolution une
expérimentation sur un corps aussi en
douleur que le corps enseignant c'est
que le corps enseignant souffre
profondément mais véritablement c'est à
dire qu'ils ont des souffrances de
reconnaissance de leur statut de leur
niveau de vie de la difficulté qu'ils
ont d'être à devoir enseigner à des
enfants qui ont beaucoup changé dont ils
ne savent pas forcément comment
enseigner c'est le cas il ya un
véritable chantier à faire et qui se
traduit aujourd'hui par de la souffrance
dans le corps enseignant en plus
d'autres souffrances qui s'ajoute avec
le fonctionnement hiérarchique qui s'est
aggravée et la confiance qui n'est pas
tout à fait présente entre les
enseignants et leur hiérarchie bref tout
ça fait qu'on a plutôt le sentiment
d'avoir un corps enseignant qui est en
souffrance mais véritablement qu'on a
une éducation nationale qui manque de
moyens emmanuel macron arrivent en
disant des bougeait pas là moi je vais
tout changer je vais tout révolutionner
banon il va falloir quand même commencé
par refaire un peu d'aidé calmer le jeu
il était comme un petit peu plus pour
savoir ce qu'ils avaient avant ses
limites je sais ce que je vais vous dire
c'est que je pense que pour que ça
marche il faut quand même avoir un socle
solide oui donnez l'école de à marseille
moi je trouve ça très bien parce que
c'est une ville très intéressant est
celui très diverses mais des écoles faut
l'épauler consolidé il faut une
électricité qui marche qu'ils peuvent
pas dans les classes b et c or tout le
monde sait qu'à marseille que le même le
bâti est très grave et très dégradé je
veux dire les enseignants sont à
marseille dans des difficultés comme le
reste de leurs collègues donc ça veut
dire qu'on va expérimenter sur la base
sur une base aussi
fragile voire en déconfiture
moi je trouve que ça ça relève un peu
d'un discours hors sol
par ailleurs il n'ya tout ce que vous
avez dit que c'est dire qu'il veut quand
même heurter des cultures meilleur temps
des cultures sans apporter les réponses
qui sont attendus il y aura des moyens
mais lesquels m peut-être revenir de
l'éducation nationale les annoncer on a
on a un peu le même quiproquos que sur
la santé exactement je suis tout sur la
santé voilà on a dit vous allez voir ce
que vous allez voir le grenelle de la
santé etc et puis vous avez vu les
professions de santé dans les temps
qu'elles elles sont elles ne sont
absolument plus convaincus par toutes
les ouvertures que tente de faire et la
danse de la santé et la défiance se
passer dans l'éducation exactement la
même mise en place du même quiproquo il
faut revaloriser et redéfinir un contrat
entre l'état et les enseignants comme il
faut le faire avec les infirmières si ce
n'est pas fait comme ça ça ne marchera
pas eh ben c'est voilà une bonne
conclusion merci à tous c'est la fin de
ce premier débat